do I ever feel like Sisyphus yeah
of course they do I've been waiting for
people to start saying like oh you put
another picture of the sweat and of a
squat rack really but I don't know if
they understand I've been getting on
that squat rack and grinding it out for
25 years and I'm not bored with it yet
it might seem like that's an unwinnable
battle but really to me it's not about
winning it it's the battle itself it's
the struggle it's the daily test that's
what life's about not just physically
but mentally getting that rock to the
top of the mountain that's not what my
goal is my goal actually is pushing the
rock because pushing the rock
a Porsches be that makes
that makes me harder mentally and
physically it gives me much more than I
give it I want to struggle I wanna go to
cause scratching I want to dig it and I
want a push and I don't want it to end
if I ever got the rock to the top of the
mountain and it's stating I push it back
down myself
and I want to rest but I don't want to
coast and I want to reach a point in my
life where I say that's it I've done
enough I'm not gonna give any more I'm
not gonna push anymore no no that
relentless cycle of day-to-day
challenges they aren't maddening to me
they don't frustrate me they inspire me
inspire me to drive and push more and to
push harder that's what that rock does
to me
so I say
begin and get to push it
[Music]
you